we're going to begin in key for a
European union and Ukrainian leaders a
meeting for the summit that's intended
to be constructive and symbolic 17
senior EU officials including the
European commission and European Council
presidents are attending it's the first
time such a summit's been held in a
country at War
Natasha Bata is joining us live now from
Kiev Natasha there's going to be a lot
on this agenda isn't there
yes indeed and EU leaders and Ukrainian
officials including of course President
Vladimir zielinski have been deep in
discussions for several hours now we are
hoping to hear from them uh as the day
goes on as what they decided we know
that there was a lot on the agenda
Ukraine certainly wants to know more
about its aspirations to become a member
of the European Union its candidacy for
the block was approved last year in June
but it wants its membership talks and
negotiations to be fast-tracked to be
sped up that is unlikely to happen EU
leaders say there are a number of
conditions and criteria that must be
fulfilled by any country to become a
full member State including things in
the media law Judiciary and Corruption
now Kiev has launched a huge
anti-corruption Drive corruption a real
problem in Ukraine for many years now a
number of top government officials were
forced to resign just last week and that
has been praised by EU leaders but they
say look that is just a first step of
course there is still a lot of work to
be done a lot of other things though
being discussed including uh more
sanctions on Russia another package in
the coming weeks the EU says also money
for things like reconstruction
rebuilding uh Ukraine so much of the
country has been badly damaged in this
war which is now nearly a year old
Natasha thank you very much indeed
Natasha Butler talking to us from Kiev
we're going to bring in Osama bin Javed
who's live for us in Moscow so Ursula
Wonderland has been saying that more
sanctions are on the way and Vladimir
zielinski is saying it's just not
happening fast enough how is Russia
reacting to all of this
but there hasn't been an immediate
reaction but we've heard from the
Kremlin in the last few hours saying
that what it wants to do is quote
protect its interests from emerging
risks and this has been the idea that
Russia has been portraying a sort of a
view of defiance in the wake of all of
these sanctions it's not just being able
to sustain much of its oil production
but it's also been able to find new
markets for its oil as these sanctions
multiple rounds of these have come into
effect the latest in the next 48 hours
which are going to be implemented by the
European Union which includes sanctions
on petrol as well as diesel products
we've been hearing from the Russian
president as well on that tone of how
the year has passed that President Putin
was saying that after 80 years the
Russians are going to be facing tanks
from Germany once again with crosses
over them and the country is prepared to
go to any length to protect its interest
and its people also it feels like that
as this war comes to a year old uh the
Defiance hasn't subsided and Russia is
trying to be inventive in ways where it
can not just sustain the sanctions that
are being imposed but circumvent them as
well Osama bin Javed in Moscow thank you